[Music]
hi I'm Natalie and we're in the
intelligence neighborhood in the sounds
and models demo and I'm joined here by
you Thank You Fang tell us a little bit
about what you do and this awesome demo
that you've created here where station
one gathering data and we have this kind
of instrument if you will but it's
actually five instruments and so each
string represents a different instrument
and we can plot our string to make
different sounds and what we're gonna do
is use this as our kind of data source
the sounds are going to then go into
data flow and get converted into
spectrogram they're gonna get moved into
this the frequency space and those
images can then be used to train our
model the hope is that these images will
be distinct enough to be able to
represent each exactly that we can tell
them apart that we can distinguish
between the instrument one two three
four and five okay so we've got our
training data now it's time to start
training the model so with Auto ml we
can train models using the data that we
had but then we don't have to do any
extra work so you can see here that the
data is coming in and you can see those
are the some of the spectrograms those
are the real data that attendees have
generated over the course of today some
images of the sound waves that's right
these are the spectrograms and then when
you train a model it just does the
training there's not much kind of work
you have to do and when it finishes
training you can have some evaluation
data that shows you the metrics around
how well the model train and how it did
so if you're new to ml that's a great
space to get started alright it's an
easy tool to get going with and if you
have some data you want to you know
throw it photo ml vision it'll take care
of it for you Haiden go do something
else with your time so we have this
board here where you can move these kind
of sliders around to different positions
and they map to different values on the
screen which changed the values of type
of parameters of the actual models
things like Colonel width and height the
layer size the number of strides as well
as the kind of number of layers you have
not actual life teeth
change the amount of code on the screen
once we're happy with you know a set of
settings that we have we can go ahead
and push the button here and start a
training job and doing that
well it'll assign us a name something
fun like spinto kappa and shoot that off
to cube flow where we have a pipeline to
do training and when i finish the
training I'll deploy it on the cloudy
aya platform prediction service so time
to moves to stage 3 in speaking of
prediction all right final stage now and
that's to predict the notes yes and so
we're gonna try to pull up the model
that we've been training it's spin so
cap it's there for us so you can turn
the crank as a selector and then press
the red button to select it select so
this is kind of like a customizable
music box and we can choose which notes
to play on which instrument you can hit
the button again so you know and this
countdown then will be able to turn this
crank now so these are these are the
notes that we set up we're gonna send
those notes off to the cloud platform
prediction service now how did we do
right was our model any good we chose
those parameters kind of randomly and so
it might be good it might not be so good
we'll we'll see right you got some of
them it seemed like it might have
actually missed a bunch it did and so
you know this is part of the machine
learning workflow this particular case a
pretty abysmal machine learning right
it's all part of the process so I think
this is a perfect demonstration to show
that so you think thank you so much for
this demonstration I think I was very
clear in kind of the three stages of
what to expect when which training
machine learning models so
thank you so much no pleasure thanks so
much Valerie back to you
[Music]